luke and nate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today we might have
bitten off more than we can chew
uh we decided we want to do a little
winter survival camping
and so we drove three hours into the
blue ridge mountains
and uh turns out the weather forecast is
completely messed up
my phone says that right now it's 40
degrees
it's not 40 degrees it's 24 degrees so
we
are significantly colder than we
expected
we'll see what happens you ready nade
yeah
let's do it
[Music]
okay try to get your leg up over there
well in a couple of weeks me and nathan
are going up to alaska to do some
survival camping videos over christmas
so i'm glad we're getting a little bit
of winter camping practice before that
you getting too hot buddy no we don't
want you sweating
yeah you get sweaty in the winter time
and then once you stop you're wet and
cold
i bet you totally could yeah there's
like a cave here
man that wouldn't be a bad place to
build a shelter except for it's muddy
and wet down there
you want to climb on top see what we can
[Music]
[Music]
see
one thing brush the snow off your pants
because that snow is going to melt
and get your pants wet you know it's
actually starting to snow again
we might get some more snow
look at this place
[Music]
yeah that is the longest icicle look at
that
look at that big icicle you got
[Music]
this is awesome oh look at that
path
yeah oh my goodness look at that
look at this you fit man
oh dad can't fit dad's too fat
that's not the way oh this is
yeah you can hold on to these roots
now careful there's a lot of cliffs here
so
if you go slow nathan
oh no i can't walk
let's go back down before we get lost
yeah we gotta we gotta climb down this
thing
is this cool or what
just be careful remember those spots are
too small i can't get down there to help
you if something bad happens
from this spot
there's a big rock
you know it's actually a bit warmer in
some of these tight spots
oh look at this one
look at this
this is just cool
i think this is one of the neatest
places we've ever hiked isn't it
you know i think even daddy can fit this
one
oh there's a little nathan spot look at
that
[Music]
i can go down this one too
[Music]
what do you think nathan should we try
to do camping here
this looks pretty good
there you go
oh he need to come back here i found the
biggest icicle ever
you want me to try to pick this one for
you
oh it's an
ice club you can club a baby seal with
that thing
[Music]
the glove's getting wet buddy
we've been here yes we have
there's our backpacks they're still safe
and sound wants to see if there's even
any left
[Music]
yeah i'll come with you
okay get down in there and lay down and
see if it's flat and comfortable
it's pretty soft but dry first things
first um i think we need to
get a bunch of firewood and we want to
have a fire to keep us warm all night it
takes a lot of wood and we need big wood
too come here
i'm gonna put my tracker on you okay
you can track me yeah but listen i want
you to stay
always where you can see me okay let's
get
some firewood
how'd you like it
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
why did you bring rope yeah i brought
for the tarp in case we needed it
i didn't just pull that out i just took
the
sheathing off this
hey nathan look at that lower lip
oh that's the liver cold camper
well having the rocks like they are
makes it really nice for keeping you out
of the smoke the wind
either blows that direction or it blows
that direction
and so i'm never in the smoke but there
is a little bit of a breeze coming in
around that corner
and uh if we can get rid of that breeze
it's gonna warm up
really good in this little crevice so
i've got a tarp that i'm gonna try to
string
over that opening
well this tarp has blocked the wind
really good
and now that fire's heat is really
getting trapped in this space between
the rocks it's
warming up pretty nice you feeling
better buddy
yeah oh it's a lot warmer in here isn't
it water dripping off the top of the
rocks from the ice melting up there
all right nathan had a little accident
he slipped on the ice and cut his hand a
little bit
put your hand out like that
let's go warm it up by the fire okay you
feeling better bud
yeah yeah that was scary wasn't it
i tend to not carry first aid kits
because anything you can fix with a
first aid kit
isn't that serious frankly but uh since
camping with nathan and the other boys
i've realized that
they really like having a first aid kit
and if you don't have it and they get
hurt
they really wonder what kind of wacko
they've gone camping with
you're glad i had the first aid kit
right yeah daddy you know the minute
[Music]
there you go okay this is about as cozy
of a survival shelter as i've ever had
but there is a little bit of a problem
here we're getting dripping
this is going up here and melting all of
that
ice and it's coming down here and it's
running here and then it is dripping
onto my sleeping bag it's dripping right
about there
it's dripping right about there it's
dripping right about there i'm hoping
that a couple hours
it might dry up a little bit and we
might get rid of this problem
but in the meantime i better move my
sleeping bag or it's going to get wet
right here come sit down
[Applause]
it's good that mine did spill the water
i really enjoy doing these winter camp
outs with nathan we had a ball last year
didn't we
yeah this last winter we we dug a snow
cave in the rocky mountains
we did camping with just a lean
too and some animal pelts in six degree
weather in alaska last winter so we've
we've had some fun adventures and we're
gonna we've got some pretty cool stuff
planned this
this winter too for the spoon
you got attacked by the gopro and you
got your desiree
well guys we got kind of lucky the
fire's melted when it's going to melt
and the drippings stopped so i don't
think we have to worry about getting
wet in the night from cave drips sun is
set
it's only 5 30. you want to sit and uh
watch a little movie
awesome
i don't know how many times we've
watched this on cam balance
how many how many hand warmers do you
want nathan here is in a 15 degree bag
and the high today was 25 so
it's gonna get cold tonight when this
fire goes out
so we are going to load him up
okay let's get you all zipped up
you want me to close up your sleeping
bag yeah
there you go
if you get cold you let me know i'll
throw more hand warmers in there okay
nathan's snoring away and the fire
stoked up
i'm gonna just kind of play it by ear
and see whether or not i let it burn all
night or not
i think i'll be warm with or without it
but it is sure comfy having this fire
the downside is i don't sleep as well
when i sleep next to a fire
because you're always worried about the
fire you know a spark flying on you and
burning a hole in your bag or something
you know so it kind of
kind of stresses me out sometimes trying
to sleep at night with the fire
but uh we'll just see what happens
well it's about four in the morning i'm
hearing some weird noises outside
sounds like either a tree fell down or
there's like a bear wandering around out
there
but uh i just stoke up the fire and
we'll see what happens well good morning
it is 7 a.m
and the sun is just beginning to rise
and we got a
little guy here who's had a good night's
sleep
you sleep well nathan yeah fire pretty
much
was on all night long and we still have
quite a bit left
so how about we stoke up the fire and
get it really warm in here you want that
there you go got some apple chicken
breakfast sausages here
gonna cook these over the fire
there you go there you go there's the
handle for your for your sausage
it got cold last night even inside the
cave there's ice in my water bottle
i'm packing everything up and i'm
getting the fire roaring so that nathan
can uh get out of a sleeping bag and get
dressed in some relative comfort
that's dad duty right there
get his clothes warmed up here
all right we're all packed up we just
need to get that fire and kind of
return things back to the way they were
as best we can
well we got everything picked up and put
back shall we go home nate
i think these trees are so cool look at
it
this place is so easy to get lost in
all right over here to the left that's
right
they got a little super boost
nathan did you have fun yeah that was
the first time i've ever slept in a cave
like an outlaw
but i hope you guys enjoyed this short
little camping and adventure video
we do lots of these sort of campouts and
check out our camping adventure playlist
with all of our videos and stay tuned
and don't forget to click subscribe
because we i've got some awesome winter
survival camping videos coming up
and i'll see you guys next saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching